Oh yours who's that loss Oh yours I'm
saying it's like my favorite lie in the
movie what are you saying or yours boy
hey what are yours all yours are yours
okay stop doing oh yours
hi my buck by my bunk anyone who hasn't
seen the critic not this critic a
different critic is totally gonna be
lost by that but who cares we're talking
about reefer madness and yeah I'll
actually I like this opening this is a
very funny opening now actually what I
was originally thinking is I was gonna
get you robbed in the dinosaur mask
Bargo it's mighty Orlando is Roger I was
gonna have you yeah and maybe vixx's um
Bjork I was gonna put you guys in the
chairs like I was talking to you you
know you were the people that came to
hear this but unfortunately there just
wasn't enough time i couldnt get
everybody together so i bet and you
didn't want a bunch of cameos stepping
on your toes well yeah of course I'm the
star I always will be and yeah you can
rot in hell I you know I give the movie
this it was truth in advertising there
was indeed a lot of reefer in this movie
and there was indeed line it was totally
mad yes totally I love the guy eating
with the flyswatter or whatever that is
yeah this just seemed like hot color
this just seemed like the logical movie
to do because it is public domain and it
really is a cult classic a sort of shag
win for endless introduction there are
Star Wars crawls that are like long as
the dark is short compared to this and
it's one of those things where it's like
you can't oh man you got just read it
you can't really just show the annoyance
of this you can't always read it out
loud so you know you do get I actually
sped it up it goes a lot so yeah it just
keeps going and going and I was like
once you just read us the whole movie
while you're at it yeah there was or
yours or yours and I I don't address it
there you accidentally get the
novelization by mistake this is the
novelization on DVD the audio boy not as
no audio oh that's true yeah it is
the book the the video book which
doesn't really make sense shocking
violence and incurable insanity
something that all things you can't get
from marijuana and something I don't
know if people will get watching this
but he actually says in the opening that
you know these narcotics or cocaine and
whatever all the hard stuff you know is
nothing compared to the marijuana I know
and I'm like really I would like to see
your medical backup on that one and
maybe were exaggerating the facts no
that's my favorite you may think the
facts are exaggerated never in that
we're little cut there the one paper
that goes away that comes back and these
people really do talk while he's talking
to her like the rudest people yeah and
look at this guy though this guy in the
movie is a principal how would you like
to have this guy is because of course
kids watching this you know the the
first person they want let's do listen
to his their principal yeah well this
was the 30s and gosh darn it listening
to the principal was swell he was swell
that swell standards feeling me I your
your joke was obviously funnier but the
thing I kept noting was I like how panic
they are about this stuff it's like man
it's not like we could do something
really dangerous like hide explosives in
people's shoes and blow up planes and I
mean this is all such chump change now
yeah this is pretty I'm in the era of
like you know al-qaeda and post 9/11 I
mean this is hilarious like oh my god
you can hide pot in shoes huh call the
authorities
oh no bring in the FBI this is and the
people burning this right now we're
probably high as a kite I'll keep
running into walls if that well the
bright jumps in the fire there's got to
be a great contact guy I'd love to have
that job just burning that stuff I love
this guy's job run around and scare
parents it's like the easiest job in the
world he's basically I don't say he's
the main character but I mean he is the
one that everybody remembers I mean he's
the main I mean he's the main visual of
the movie he's the boogeyman drugs drugs
a broom yeah I mean just the fact that
they got this guy to be like
voice of reason and everything when he
just so clearly looks insane
he clearly looks like he's done some
drugs that's the thing I mean even
though it's Angry belligerent basically
on some sort of speed at least
after-school specials got the idea that
you know make it about the kids there's
over the top they are it's like hey if
the how's this affect the kids and let
the kids say about that's like no it's
like the principal is telling you how
your kids are thinking and then she put
under stacking slowly yeah what was up
with this I don't know I this was
straight-up porn back that in the
principal story YK and then we spend
forever why should you put on her
stockings yeah I think I call it
pantyhose at a house pointed out they're
not technically pantyhose but who cares
it's it's a fantasy let him dream but
whatever let the principal dream you can
tell they're on marijuana because
they're all very stilted well and the
fight that yeah I'm gonna blow out serve
I'm like well can I make it like a
blowjob joke or blow like the drug I'm
like no just say it's too easy it's like
to make possibilities I like how this is
a world entirely supposedly inhabited by
quote-unquote kids but they all look
like they're 40 every kid back I don't
know if the kids actually looked older
back then because of the hairstyles or
whatever or if it's just you know they
got these villains or back then 10 was
the new 20 I guess it makes sense
anytime I can have a meter I'm all for
it I love the how your mom would find
this well I love the little head of the
kid laughs oh yeah transition it's high
cut cut but more buts what what what in
the butt dancing that's being weird
dancing was invented it that's the get
him to come home to change I gonna be
definitely look like Kramer
yeah Kramer and all forgetting his
name's Jimmy Durant was as named they
ain't cat think I do watch each other
tonight Mary Jane out for an assembly I
don't know around
Durant that's it
I think it's one line where he says you
know hey you want dance sure and I said
no no no dance not whatever the hell
visits this guy know it's like the
principal and this guy the most
memorable who people and we have no idea
where that guy is I mean they say his
name but it's like what easy working for
the mobsters is just bad by the way both
hands together just shitty it's like a
Tasmanian delegate it is funny that this
film just gets so many things about drug
use so slightly wrong they really needed
more people who've actually used drugs
to write it well in the polling dynamite
they're the most painful scene in the
movie right here right oh god I died a
little inside honest really you're gonna
actually put that on screen we achieve
new levels of swell miss Peter Parker is
in this door key what the hell hey I
wonder if kids at you dress like this
babe le with the bowtie in store this is
just how adults thought kids dressed I
owe Andy I'm sure maybe if you had money
like you know I Oh
korto fellow quota fellow they suppose
been high schooler count that high
school does have a grotto remember when
when you were asking for like 20 minutes
what it was and I kept yeah it's a
grouting or like no there's another word
it's a grotto no there's another word
found no another word the grotto alright
I think it's a grotto I I think there is
another word for it I know we well a
grommet and pull bird bath grotto thingy
yeah grotto fireworks best yeah I never
drink that stuff
Mourad are you I think it's a root beer
hello Jose I'm not into that stuff I've
learned a hard liquor oh yeah yeah and
then he gets the root beer instead what
the hell was up with there but I like
how high school kids like hang out with
35 year olds in yeah there's another
tell your children message here god
we now write all that dad say love it
did people get hurt dancing like that
one that like when her shoe go up his
ass pretty fast
look at that let her down that what
don't you get like yeah I don't
understand like if you do that sort of
thing you get a car you can't inhale a
gulp like that I mean she swallowed it
but at least go
why based on the thing she's obviously
not inhaling it just serve a quick and
then oh you know like just nothing at
all I be it's not going down to the
lungs at all and that's actually I think
that's a if I'm right I think it's only
way you can get high you have to let it
go down to the law you have to inhale it
you can't just let you know it swirl
around your mouth
I believe less you do it for like a
super super long time that's just
wasteful that's wasting your drugs oh
they look pretty huge - I mean those
look almost like cigarillos I have no
idea but I got is great pardon me I I
just saw that online I'm just like
that's a good picture you look stoned I
think even a little title under it just
says you know he looks stoned so good to
see you around puke bag again they're
not rolling their own either because
those look like professionally made
cigarettes again when it did you see one
machine they have an hour wait known as
err I didn't show it in this like they
have low machines like that make
cigarette yeah okay so this is like the
smallest dirt town anywhere but they
have the most advanced narcotics
operation running there are machines
there are accountants there's all sorts
of crazy it's so much fun to see people
who obviously have a never been high and
B never seen anybody who's been high try
to act high because they still look like
they're on speed instead hello Barbie
its dr. Cox guy it won't that get mix
between dr. Cox and Walt Disney that
would have made this movie much better
if it was Walt Disney running the drug
app that would have been a twist that
totally love it it's list he was the
voice of Mickey to your manager which
you could have done with that
um all your friends are doing it huh
yeah yeah I think there's allies like I
sure wish you had a couple of kids that
I said yeah I'll tear you bring up that
I may procreate someday yeah I like how
the do it's very Godfather it's just
like they'll commit murder larceny
racket but yeah kiss hi yeah that's
where you know Corleone draws the line
the same thing here it's like you were
we were getting people home would be
like mom I'm not doing what marijuana oh
yeah
come on my baby daughter does marijuana
by the way I like how everybody could
see that car which was topless and see
the two people inside but nobody can
figure out who did it this is a small
town I should buy about that brendan
fraiser joke for anyone who didn't get
that there's an episode of scrubs where
like with a brendan fraiser yeah it's
our the sixth sense episode where
Brendan Fraser's a days this great guy
makes lots of jokes instead translation
she was dead the whole time okay well I
guess you don't have to see it now cuz
don't just spoil me I don't care it's a
terrible episode you're gonna hate the
twist anyway so that's why they had some
reference to I should but I don't hate
scrubs I hate parts of it I hate when it
tries to be serious that's where it
really fucking he's really really funny
though it's not ya know I can get some
good jokes but yeah when it's serious it
is shit the little guitar going and say
yeah I like how he said yeah he just
inserts himself in the story I'm
surprised it didn't end taxi driver sat
with him with like a machine gun like
blowing away all the drug dealers that
my girlfriend came up wearing nothing
but pantyhose and we kissed for hours
and it was swell was this like I should
have done a little count like cameo
appearance like two three something like
that the principal calls him in just
four random questioning it really was a
dark time
if you weren't smoking pod you were you
know a communist it's like yeah are you
smoking pot yes but you're not communist
now okay you're okay
I think it's some point I make a slug
we're at the show he really does what I
mean yeah this is your heroes this is
the guy look at him you're supposed to
side with this guy who would not decide
even if you would say the truth you
wouldn't want side with them reminds me
of that guy on the world's best police
chases or whatever that shows he's all
team all teeth they're gonna have a
splendid party
this is not high on pot this is just
pure antisocial psychosis guy psychotic
he's just a sociopath no that would be a
great twist into the fact that there was
never any marijuana
that'd be a great twist that would be
your twist ending there was never any
marijuana well then what were we doing
oh how much energy these people have
while they're on marijuana - that's my
favorite yeah like pretty much you just
want to eat Doritos and sit on the couch
these quotes are great
oh this had - it was so cuz this is
already flowed down a bit but I had two
really really bad at it tight didn't we
lift this from I wanna say Naked Gun or
something didn't they do something
similar I remember oh no hot tub yeah
read my I just say yeah just say if they
accept they only deal once I felt lazy
flaviu just putting more random lines
yeah no that's pretty brilliant
I get public domain stuff we can get
away with stuff those on the news and
stuff oh that looks like a deep wound
right looks like a fly like just a fly -
would have been more effective who
completely blew her head off love an
awesome this is like blood everywhere
yeah I love these gangsters now see yeah
you did it wake up check it out Shadia
you wanted
I thought the mary-jane lion was fire
but uy like when they speedway they
weapon
boom-boom-boom plant so cartoonish and
they do it the whole way back to the
wall like you cut early but what is
scooby-doo I think the kids are right
there you can hear everything I mean
technically they don't say anything that
could be held against it that's like
alright here's the story it's like as
soon as you hear that it's like life
they're just to do his bidding no matter
how great it is his wife could just be
some too bad my god all right goodbye
sober life and then he's in the
courtroom he's everywhere his glasses
biggest role omnipresent shadow I used
to think it was a great boy but now I
think you're fine American boy yeah I
tried a few jokes I tried Walia table
like those lousy Canadian girls are say
it's like I don't know but it that
slugworth light seem to work best I love
this impression of Jerry - they're all
just like oh we should set an example
let's hang him and one doesn't say
guilty I'm gonna eat you but you are you
fuckers I like how easily their turn to
but but what if you didn't know we need
to set an example
I agreed let's kill him yeah this is
like the worst juror you can possibly
have and they were wrong Washington's
there like Washington says hang the
bastard and they technically are wrong
because he didn't do it
I mean am i you should lynch him guilty
bear went ahead here I had kill the
Beast
kill the Beast but Chris offense a lot
funnier oh god father what he looks like
he fell directly out of the Godfather
looks like ya Duvall yeah Robert
Duvall's character faster this is at
your house this ain't how I heard about
it um I'll go for a mine here her
parents were talking about me I just
read this movie format all I remember is
that marijuana makes you play the piano
faster yes all I remember
I remember we I remember we watched this
and this is our favorite scene I really
like using that guy it's supposed to be
the future critic but I've been using it
more it's just a basic Doc Brown
character is that you a lot of fun to
use I love the way says he crazy
don't call oh yeah I can never tell
she's must be crying or laughing there
really I figured it out this isn't an
anti-drug movie it's a David Lynch film
hi radically Eraserhead makes a lot more
sense yes it does after the guy playing
the piano maybe that was eraser head now
it could be houses cameo under arrest
Disney she sort of looks like that
chipmunk cheek with you guys they get
the close-up that's my favorite the soft
focus close-up she's just swallowing
large gulps of air there's actually a
little bit where she has like a
flashback to all the terrible things
she's done that's where she gets the
idea of it kids hi goodbye yeah you
notice it's not like she just jumped out
she had to somehow break that window and
then get on the lens oh she had that
just like winger really would have to
fly
yeah I love it somehow he's still high I
guess they just lost him to insanity
done so much pod he's insane
sure marijuana can make you paranoid but
this guy's just got a screw errs now
God you know there are plenty of bad
drugs you shouldn't do out there to
begin with and if you want to do a PSA
about that fine but it's the way they're
wilfully wired it doesn't we should make
it clear I mean we certainly don't think
yet everybody should light up and be
high and stuff lot of it's really not
for drug use that's because real life's
weird enough as it is yeah you don't
need to make a weirder but I mean
they're just it's just willful lying I
mean you really have been lied to this
entire special I wish I have that little
static thing even though it's still
obviously not on the TV this is online
yet I still use that little static cliff
all the time it's like as a was the line
I had if it's the Woody Allen of drugs
its ineffectual and annoying at best to
be around to try to claim that it's
basically the end of civilization as we
know it is not only disingenuous that
completely ruins your point now from an
ethical standpoint I really think they
should legalize it or at the very least
make alcohol illegal because we're just
fucking hypocrites when we do that that
really pisses me off it's like just at
least try to be consistent though I like
the argument that a lot of people don't
want it legalized because government
pots gonna suck it'll be young you can
develop make it better no I never did
that but the point is that this film
gets it entirely wrong and if this is
the big threat in this area where we've
era where we've got some guy lighting
his shoes on a plane to kill 200 people
in midair because I drugs no no no no we
don't need to worry about that that we
need to worry about the marijuana that
may be hidden in the shoe yes that's
right
he's probably what the guy is doing he's
probably lighting up with one shoe and
then lighting the other shoe on fire so
we see goes out hot via interesting way
to go you know it was particularly dirty
yeah I may I put that a little too much
it's not it's the lighting too I just
got a new light around this point so
it's a little overexposed but I'm still
trying to get used to it
it's rare to have it overexposed to it
most I love this sound I love my music
Oh such a cliche Doug the homeless crack
addict
yeah I'm terrible snorting coke yeah
well I'm not saying they all do what
you're saying chester does i think you
said but you have to put it in formally
tell your children oh yeah it was always
like formally to tell your children get
addicted to hot chocolate kids grind up
Pixy sticks and snort that